hallo mein Name ist Luca meine lieben
Freunde ihr fragt euch wahrscheinlich
warum ich euch jetzt hier mit meinem
Handy nebenbei Filme das sieht
allerdings ganz einfach daran weil ich
euch mal eben kurz mein Setup für heute
zeigen wollte ich habe nämlich ein
Logitech Lenkrad organisiert mit Pedalen
und alles gesichert mit Bierkästen weil
bei meinem Schreibtischstuhl immer nach
hinten gerollt ist als ich Gas gegeben
habe ich nur aufgebaut weil wir heute
endlich
City Car driving spielen das ist einfach
ein professioneller
fahrschulprüfungssimulator
das heißt ich werde heute absolut gar
keinen Unfall bauen das ist unsere Karte
für den heutigen Tag niedriges
Tankfüllstand wir können jetzt auf Enter
klicken und dann sehen wir schon oben
rechts haben wir eine Route nämlich
2,343 km zur nächsten Tankstelle ich
schalte erstmal rückwärts das Video
unten rechts in den reverse Gang
Rückwärtsgang und jetzt fahren wir ganz
langsam raus ich werde mich wirklich an
alle Verkehrsregeln heute halten Gott
wir fahren vorwärts erstmal
Allerwichtigste
halte Regeln verletzt ich habe im Radio
angemacht aber gut okay wir geben Gas
wir fahren los ganz entspannt immer
wichtig entspannte Musik hören ich
Switch mal zum nächsten Sender zurück
sehr gut okay also wir müssen hier links
abbiegen das ist aber eine abbiegende
Vorfahrtsstraße so das heißt blinken so
jetzt vorsichtig reintasten um die Ecke
von immer muss ja aber auch cool ne so
okay abgebogen sind wir Blinker aus und
ja
[Musik]
ich sag zweiter Gang und ich schalte wie
ein Weltmeister zack dritter Gang wie
findest du hier wahrscheinlich weniger
ne 80 wird wahrscheinlich nicht in der
Stadt so ein zurückschalten zweiter Gang
sehr gut machen wir entspannt wir wollen
den Vordermann ja auch nicht hetzen hier
ein bisschen schneller geht schon hallo
hier ist 50 nicht 46
[Musik]
er das war kein richtiger Unfall wir
sind noch immer im Rennen noch immer in
der fahrschulprüfung drin so der vor uns
fährt sehr gut rechts geht äh geht's
einfach in die Stadt stand auf dem
Schild so um die Kurve zack links
einordnen wir müssen jetzt den Blinker
ausmachen und in die andere Richtung
blinken sehr gut so wie steht der denn
da
sag mal wie fahren die denn alle
sind die bekloppt soll ich mal hier
[Applaus]
[Musik]
90 km/h
100 km/h
rüber zack vierter Gang sehr gut sehr
sehr gut jetzt hier schön
ganz knapp dazwischen her sehr gut
müsste nicht hupen ne ich mache was ich
hier das ist so wie wir mit tik tok
unten steht professionelle Handlungen
zack 5 ich habe vergessen zu schalten
verdammt okay jetzt müssen wir ganz klar
ja der war schon kaputt
haben wir ein Totalschaden schneiden Sie
sich ansteht ab muss man bei mir nicht
den kann man auch so vertrauen
Entschuldigung Achtung
[Musik]
sehr gut hier vorne müssen wir links
abbiegen das heißt Blinker setzen sehr
gut und ab nach links fahren wir einfach
mal
stabil Alter
ich muss schnell zur Tankstelle
[Musik]
Weg sehr gut und jetzt nur hier rechts
rein linker setzen oh hey dieser Margret
sehr gut jetzt geht's los achtung ich
muss zur Tankstelle Entschuldigung Oma
ist Opas
[Musik]
ich kann nicht mal Sonnenschild umfahren
setzen wir halt wieder zurück machen
erstmal auf den Blinker aus fahren
wieder vor habe zur Tankstelle so
[Musik]
ja die nehmen wir auch noch mal kurz mit
hallo haben wir hier noch mehr Leute ne
der hier da vorne ist ja auch schon
beschwert über unsere zack braucht man
nicht die brauchen alle nicht hier jeder
vorne auch nicht mit 100 km/h durch die
installiert so junge zack zack zack zack
zack zack Triple oh oh
aber es ist krass was unser Auto alles
mitmacht guck mal wir kommen hier
überall lang sehr gut erster Gang wir
sind sofort da oh was steht da für eine
Werbung lovely
Schönheitssalon schön ich fahre wie ein
geborenes Stück Butter ne Wahnsinn hier
im dritten Gang durch die Innenstadt mit
90 genauso wie man das machen sollte
schon runterschalten den zweiten Gang
Blinker setzen ah vergessen egal können
sie sich ja denken Moment
Sonnenschild das können wir doch wohl
mitnehmen
gut sag weiter geradeaus zweiter Gang da
vorne rechts haben wir die Tankstelle
sehr schön da sind immer jetzt Blinker
setzen stabil zack runterschalten
[Musik]
in der Kraftstoff im Tank niedrige nee
jetzt ist der zum Tanken bleiben Sie auf
der richtigen Seite der Tanksäule stehen
Herr schalten Sie die Handbremse an
neutralen stellen Sie den Motor ab okay
[Musik]
drücken Sie Enter ach so gedrückt halten
wir machen wollen
ab zur Autobahn ich kann aber noch den
Weg ich kenne ja meine Hund hier ne
Birgit hi hallo so sehr gut ne oh mein
Gott
guck mal modernes bitte okay geradeaus
geht ins moderne Viertel angeblich würde
ich sagen schauen wir uns erstmal das
moderne Viertel dahinten an danach
geht's ab zur Autobahn also das ist hier
das moderne Viertel oder was
ja wir versuchen jetzt mal ein
Geschwindigkeitsrekord hier aufzustellen
wir sind bei 100 km/h schalten jetzt mal
hoch im vierten Gang vielleicht schaffen
wir 150 das wäre schon sehr sehr wild
wir sind immer 125 oh Gott da hinten
kommt eine Ampel kommen 130 ey das
kriegen sonst müssen okay es ist nur
eine Kurve 140 km/h sehr gut sehr gut
sehr gut ich schalte gleich sofort hoch
in 5 Minuten
150 km/h meine Damen und Herren springen
schon spring hier wir springen noch
nicht ich schalte hoch 5 Gang ab durch
die Innenstadt 150 140 wir sind wieder
runtergekommen aber egal ich bin sehr
sehr gut im Rennen gerade sehr sehr gut
auf Dauer kriegen wir auf jeden Fall die
Omi hi
hi moin jetzt sind wir auf der Autobahn
komm mal jetzt geht's los hier der
Geschwindigkeitsrekord meine Damen und
Herren unser Tank ah der streikt ein
bisschen aber das ist egal wir haben ein
Ziel und wir haben einen Weg dieser Weg
heißt Autobahn und das sieht halt 200
km/h 150 haben wir drei Viertel haben
wir geschafft ab jetzt nur noch
schwieriger meine Damen und Herren denn
jetzt noch weiter zu beschleunigen
schwierig und vor allem hier durch den
Verkehr durchzukommen ich bin aber
eingeborenes Naturtalent und mach das
bisher super gut wir sind bei 160 kmh
angelangt machen wir sehr gut
machen wir sehr gut
wir machen das so unfassbar gut wir
gehen hoch in 5 Gang oh mein Gott 162
schafft dieses Auto 200 km/h es wäre
einfach nur ein Meilenstein in der
Geschichte nicht nur in der Geschichte
von City Car driving sondern auch in der
Geschichte der Menschheit wir werden im
Guinness Weltrekord Buch stehen 162
irgendwie komme ich schneller ne
eine Stunde
jetzt haben wir irgendwie die ganze
Autobahn hier blockiert an der Stelle
ige Video Freunde wenn euch CityCard
driving hier
miteinander Scan einen Daumen hoch unter
dem Video hier da abonniert meinen Kanal
und Klick auf die Glocke um weitere
Videos verpassen danke an Logitech dass
sie mir das Lenkrad hierzu geschickt
haben ich glaube ich kann damit noch
nicht so gut umgehen